for the sixth week in a row Democrats in
Congress are trying to force Donald
Trump to release his tax returns now
they're threatening to delay any tax
reform legislation until Trump releases
the tax returns Trump has said that tax
reform is the next big agenda item that
he plans to tackle of course after the
epic failures of to immigration bands
and an Obamacare repeal and replacement
known as the American Health Care Act
which died fortunately and
embarrassingly ten days ago we have New
York congressman Hakeem Jeffries who's
been a guest on this show before he has
introduced a resolution that would
direct the house to delay the
consideration of any tax reform
legislation until we see Trump's tax
returns it is no secret that Donald
Trump and his cronies would probably
benefit financially from whatever tax
proposal Trump is going to put out there
and of course the only way we can really
know how does the guy passing the new
tax law benefit from the new tax law the
only way we can know that is if we look
at Trump's taxes publicly we know Trump
has called for eliminating the
alternative minimum tax which requires
high-income taxpayers to pay a minimum
amount in taxes regardless of itemized
deductions that they claim you'll
remember that last month MSNBC's Rachel
Maddow disclosed two pages of trumps
2005 tax return it ended up not really
being the bombshell that it was promised
to be but the documents did tell us that
Trump and his wife paid 38 million in
taxes on 153 million in income in 2005
most of that was an alternative minimum
tax and more than likely Pat whatever
reforms Trump wants would drastically
reduce his personal tax liability but we
don't know for sure because we don't see
the taxes I'm concerned that Rachel
Maddow sending out those 2005 tax
returns and also his 1995 tax returns
being public yeah will allow him to
argue well people have seen my tax
returns at this point and there was
obviously nothing to hide from that even
though we got to see a lot more the 2005
two pages of the 1040 form tells us
basically nothing about the specific
conflicts that Donald Trump may have and
I want to directly asked Trump support
years what's the big deal with Trump
disclosing his taxes I mean if it's
really no big deal that he not disclosed
them why is it a big deal that he
disclosed them seventy-four percent of
Americans want to see them according to
a recent gallup poll presidents for the
last forty years have released their tax
returns and again if you're at answer is
it's not important that he uh isn't
releasing them then why would it be a
big deal if he did release them i think
their argument is that it's a private
matter and he has the right to conceal
his own tax returns and the problem with
that is he's president of the united
states he's not just a public servant
he's the top public servant in the whole
country so in a way he's a public figure
he's an extension of the whole country
in a way yeah i mean what an
understatement it i think that it would
be a fair rule to say if you're making
tax law we should see how the tax law
impacts you personally right i mean
there's no this is the person whose
taxes we should see it's like how
congress can't raise their own pay any
pay increases have to take effect in the
next congress oh right yeah i forgot it
thats actually good example and the
congressional pay thing is also relevant
with the government shutdown if you're
going to shut down government then you
shouldn't still get paid and of course
they do still get paid when they shut
down government yeah you're not going to
be an essential service in our heads
yeah absolutely if you can't even keep
government running how essential could
you possibly be why do you need to keep
earning a salary so the most powerful
man in the country who plays a large
role in lawmaking and policy wants to
change the tax code should we just trust
him or should we maybe figure out how
those changes to the tax code would
impact him and his cabinet as well as
everything else that might be revealed
by the tax returns i think i remember
seeing something Pat that trumps cabinet
and Trump combined have the same well as
like you know some crazy percentage of
the population of the United States I
don't remember that but you've seen
those statistics well it's not
surprising because i think it's six or
eight people the top the most rich
people in the whole world that the
billionaires the top 1% of 1% have more
combined wealth than the bottom half of
the world combined yeah yeah yeah and
these these are statistics that bernie
sanders very successfully we
tell people about during his
presidential campaign so Donny boy show
us the tax returns will this proposal
from Hakeem Jeffries exposed the tax
returns I say probably not